You are listening to radiolab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
So you're gonna identify the Washington place cause I can't remember what, yeah,
yeah. Okay. Three, two, one. Ready?
I am ready but we should tell the audience that we're not gonna.
We're gonna start this not in our usual studios spot. Not here.
Here where we're sitting now here.
Okay.
Just to explain, this is the Shakespeare theater in DC.
Recently Robert and I were there in front of about 800 folks just trying out
some material for the show.
We're getting with this story which comes from Pleateau actually by way of
Aristophanes. It's a 2,400 year old story breaking news. In other words,
and it goes like this.
Once upon a time he says people were not born separate from each other.
They were born intertwined, kind of coupled with each other.
So they were boys attached to boys and they were girls attached to girls and of
course boys and girls together in a wonderfully intimate ball.
And back then we had eat limbs. They were four on top, four on the bottom.
And you didn't have to walk if he didn't want to. You could roll and roll.
We did. We rolled backwards and we rolled forwards achieving fantastic speeds.
That gave us a kind of courage.
And then the courage swelled to pride and the pride became arrogant.
And then we decided that we were greater than the gods and we tried to roll up
to heaven and take over heaven and the gods alarms struck back.
And Zeus in his fury hurled down lightning bolts and struck everyone into,
into perfect halves. So all of a sudden,
couples who'd been warm and tight and wedged together,
we're now detached and alone and lost and desperate and losing the will to live.
And the gods seen what they'd done,
worried that humans might not survive or even multiply again.
And of course they needed humans to give sacrifices and pay attention to them.
So the gods decided on a few repairs,
instead of heads facing backwards or out,
they would rotate our heads back to forward.
They pulled our skin taut and nodded it right here at the belly button.
Genitalia too, were moved to the front. So if we wanted to, you know, we could,
and most important, they left us with a memory.
It was a longing for that original other half of ourselves,
the boy or the girl who used to make us whole.
And that longing is still so deep in all of us. Men for men, women for women,
men for women for each other,
that it has been a lot of humans ever since to travel the world looking for our
other half. And when says Aristophanes when one of us meets another,
we recognize each other right away. We just know this.
We're lost in an amazement of love and friendship and intimacy.
We won't get out of each other's sight even for a moment. These are people,
he says who their whole lives
together. And yet if you ask them,
they could not explain what they desire of each other.
They just do.
Very nice. Thank you very much. Thank you.
[inaudible].
So here's the thing. That story got us started on a little journey.
Truly began just thinking about wholeness and oneness and has looking for each
other in all varieties of ways, mirrors and shapes, relationships.
Beauty, the birth of the universe, the nature of life.
All of these things either have a simple deep beauty or
not.
I'm Jad Abumrad I remember Krulwich this is Radiolab and today for this hour we
are desperately seeking the symmetry.
By the way. That was Zoe Keating on cello.
We'll hear more from earth throughout the hour cause she's awesome.
Everybody. Kay [inaudible] I'm still thinking about our and he's okay. And uh,
you ever wonder, uh,
what actually happens when two people click when the haves kinda meat,
meaning what? You know, you going through your day, maybe you're at a party.
Yeah. You meet people and you're like, hey, how are you? How are you?
And they say something,
they try and be interesting and you try and be interesting back.
But in the end you're like, damn, I don't need to remember that name. Right?
Of course. Yeah, it's gone.
And then comes along, somebody, every hundred dimes,
the stars align, the world falls away. Things narrow and you just
click. I know that.
Did you ever wonder what actually happens in that moment?
Like when you meet someone that you really get it? I just,
I don't think that there's anything that really feels better than that.
That's Lauren silver. She's a neuroscientist at Princeton. She wonders,
she has been wondering for awhile and I was, I don't know, maybe eight.
And I used to study with my dad.
We would go over things and I remember like I didn't understand this one like
math problem and he was explaining it to me and all of a sudden and I got it and
I started to cry and he got really nervous cause I was crying.
Why are you crying? Cause I was so excited that I like finally got it.
That's my first memory of really like d excited about the intensity of
understanding. So fast forward 20 years,
Lauren is a Princeton and in the basement of our building here.
Can you just tell me where we are?
We are in the Fri facilities in Green Hall at Princeton University.
They've got this giant brain scan, get magnet,
looks like an airplane engine will like a Donut, not pretty good donut.
And as you know with the scanner you can put people in it and have them do
tasks. Think, think a thought or things, Huh?
Sing a song or watch a movie and a then the researchers can see into their
brain, you know, without having to cut in there and got it into her head.
Could I use this big donut to investigate the clicking question?
So is the question when things click, what clicks, what clicks?
And if we can know what clicks can we learn how to make it click more?
So one day last year, Lauren got into the brain scanner,
I sort of like it in there and she told this story and you just tell me that
story. Uh, well it's a 15 minute, come on. Okay.
So I told the story.
Vert actually told you the whole thing without any sort of rehearsal fully,
maybe for something,
something under 30 under 30 times.
I'm going to tell it one more time for everybody else. Play a loss.
So the story is about her prompt.
So Lauren is in high school and this guy that she doesn't really like as you go
to the prompt, it's pretty awkward, but she's like, okay, you know,
didn't know what to say. Now subsequent to being asked by the first guy,
she actually falls for real for a second guy. Guy Number two.
We just liked each other quick.
So now she has a situation cause she likes the second guy said yes,
the first guy and he still wants to be the day he wants to be. Oddly enough,
he still wants to go there. So she ends up going with guy number one.
So we get to the problem and a guy number two,
her boyfriend shows up drunk,
very drunk and punches fly. It gets messy.
So she drags Gamer to her boyfriend out to the parking lot,
but on the way to the car he trips and falls directly on his face right onto his
face on the concrete and he starts bleeding profusely.
So she's like, Oh give me your keys. I'm going to drive. I'll drive her car.
And she doesn't have a license but he can't drive.
So she drives them both out of the parking lot.
A couple of minutes later they come upon an accident in the street. Yeah,
that's right there. Some cars had gone into a thing.
So they're rolling up to it.
I get distracted and she crashes into the accident that had already happened and
it's just that the police were already there and they're like, watch.
So the officer walks up, sees her no license,
sees this dude who's all bloody and messy and was like, all right,
give me your registration. She thinks she's going to jail.
But here is where fate steps in as the officer is walking back to his car with
her registration, a wind, a lucky way. One of those kicks up,
blows the registration out of the officer's hands.
He can't find it and he has no choice but to let her go. So then I just left.
So that was the story that forms the basis.
That is the story that forms the basis of the pressure. Okay,
so now let's rewind. So anyhow,
she told that story in the scanner, all the while,
the scanner snap pictures of her brain, moment to moment.
Then she got a bunch of other people,
put them in the scanner and have the scanner snap pictures of their brain as
they're listening to the story with me so far. Next,
she compared brains. Okay,
so here I can show you a,
Lauren showed us brain scans where she divided each brain into thousands of tiny
little squares. So we called voxels thousands. Thousands. Yeah.
So then what we can do is we can take one box or in one brain and directly
compare it to the same exact vox or in the other brain. Shut up.
Wow. And we do this across the entire brain.
And this is where things get interesting when people really got her story,
because she had run them through all these tests to see if they could remember
the different chapters, the word she used.
So she was checking to see how well they listened. Yeah.
She would have them kind of recall the story of them.
Some were really good at recalling others, not so much. Now,
the people that did well, like really well,
she found that as they were listening to her story,
their brain would literally begin to mirror hers.
All the little voxels in their head would start to sync up with all the little
voxels in her head. So they're, so they're just listening.
Like anyone listening, just hearing [inaudible]
you're saying it again? I get that. No, no.
Let me put it to you a different way. You're right. I mean,
right now you and I are voxels are mirroring each other. You know,
we're both speaking English. Yeah. So we can assume,
say 20% at least I would go 23, 24 let's say 24. Okay.
But let's say you bump it up to 30, maybe bump it up to 35.
Let's get a little higher. 40 42 48,
49 at a 50% left.
But let's say we get to 50%, even 60.
There's a certain point at which something happens where it's no longer me just
describing an experience to you.
It's you actually having the experience, you know, uh,
like you know that the difference between ex explanation and experience is like
the Grand Canyon, right? Well she's found a way to quantify the gap.
So when I'm sitting there listening to Meryl Streep, I'm all Merrill inside,
outside and all around. Yeah, that's 100% Merrill without lasting,
that's 100% Merrill Street. He is not listening to this. You were saying,
I'll give you an example of [inaudible].
I was just saying here, let me show you. So while I was in Lauren's office,
she showed me this particular slide of her results.
So on this side we have this comprehension rank and what that means basically is
a graph.
And on one axis shoot she had how much they actually understood the story and
could recall it.
And on the other axis she had how much their brain sinked up with hers,
which is sort of like how much they experienced the story. What are these marks,
by the way? Are these people, sorry about the way these,
oh, these are individual subjects. So if you take out this one outlier,
actually,
she pointed to this one subject who was way on one side of the graph because
that person is just didn't get your story at all. No, this person actually,
that person did understand her story score really nice on comprehension but just
didn't sync up with her brain at all. This person. Yeah.
Um,
this person I t well,
so this is a little interesting tidbit.
I know this person, you know this person, I know this person. Yeah.
Hm. To that person. I'm almost positive is her fiance. Yeah,
it was, there were some fights in gesture for real.
I mean for real. I don't think he was actually paying attention.
Um, but this one up here, she pointed to another subject.
Oh the way on the other side of the graph, who is a super brain coupling.
Master a was a, a girl in Undergrad who I had never met before.
Um,
and her brain coupled with my brain was twice as much as everybody else.
I mean really just like I contacted her after cause I wanted to like have lunch
with her and just see for the same person or not.
And you never got back to me. What I know is not really,
it was sort of the end of their semester and I think she might've been away in
the weeks after I spoke with Lauren.
We emailed a few times and I kept asking her. I was like,
so what about that girl? The one who knew everything? Yeah,
like how do you explain the connection? Is it a connection?
[inaudible] he didn't want to know. She did actually.
And we started referring to the girl on email as a
BD media, meaning what? Meaning?
Brain Double Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi [inaudible] bring a little,
bring the book here. Anyhow,
eventually after two weeks of constant emailing and searching,
BD turns up and agrees to me.
The meeting took place on a sunny Tuesday afternoon at Princeton and I missed it
because I was on the wrong train. When I finally get there,
BD has come and gone. So you never laid eyes on BD? I did not,
but I talked to Lauren right after she had,
it was weird really. We sat down on a bench and she gave me the skill. Okay.
You seem a little shaken. Yeah, it was a strange experience.
First thing she tells me is what the mystery girl's name is. Her name. Lauren.
My name is la. She was Lauren. And you were Lauren? Yes.
We're both named Lauren. Wow. I know. It's weird,
but there's clients out there. I know, but still, that's so weird.
At this point I'm like, I mean,
this was like an error stuff and he's whopper here, folks. So I was thinking,
and that's what Lauren told me, that she had been expecting to beforehand.
I was expecting her to come in and just be me.
And when she showed up with she, you know, not at all.
Yeah.
Earlier they admitted to coffee shop and a, since I'd missed the whole thing,
I was very lucky that more number one had recorded the meeting on her laptop.
Okay. So I want to know, did you, where did you grow up?
I grew up in Vancouver. C in Vancouver. Yeah.
Loren one's theory was that they would have a common background or common,
something that would explain the symmetry between them.
But what you hear Lauren one, I'm looking for points of connection and uh,
consider yourself well listen. Okay. Do you have prom in Canada?
Is that a stupid question? Well we do. I actually couldn't go to mine.
You didn't go to your prom? Yeah. Okay. Uh, I wish I could.
Did you, um,
did you have like significant relationships in high school? No.
No, not at all. I went to an all girls school. You went to an all girls school?
Yeah. Did you have to wear a unicorn? Yeah. Was it like happen in the end?
There was not one thing they had in common except their names and
Princeton. Do you thought that this was going to be, you know, something?
I don't know. Is it, maybe your premise is wrong. What do you mean? Well,
actually I eat,
snuck up to Columbia University and I asked her neuroscientist about this
actually. When did you do that while you were in Princeton?
I was on the subway going up to see Joey her. Hi.
Nice to meet you went behind my back. What happened is I said to her, look,
we have this pretty great paper, and she agreed. It was a wonderful paper.
I said, it shows these two women who has seemed to be in such lock step.
Wouldn't you suppose that the two of them, if they ever met,
would become friendly or have some connection? Yeah.
You come to the same conclusion if yours and my heartbeats were exactly the
same.
Depends on the circumstances.
If it was a beautiful night at a sinking moon in Venice, maybe
yes. You have elaborated the story beyond my question.
Say Your heartbeat is about 62 beats per minute. Same.
Mine was exactly 62 beats per minute.
Would you say that we were more in sync than if mine was 72 beats per minute
that you and I were more soulmates? No, probably not. Well, I don't want to,
but I, I don't know if I, you see, I would want to, don't you want to,
when you see synchrony between individuals?
Well, yes,
but I'm saying that I think that the conclusion doesn't follow from the data.
Joy says it's equally possible that Lauren too is just an extraordinarily good
listener.
Hello? Hey. Hey. Can you hear me okay? Yeah, I can hear you. In fact,
when I finally got Lauren to on the phone, uh,
she did tell me that she is one of those people that when she hears a story,
she just falls in
to the point where somebody can be a [inaudible].
And I don't it because I'm so focused on it. But yeah. Um,
how do I explain it? So have you ever done any, any sports?
Yah. Soccer a little bit. Yeah.
Do you ever find that sometimes when you're playing soccer,
you are so into the game?
Are you just reacting or whatever that you kind of lose track of yourself for a
little bit?
Yeah. It's like a dream state almost.
Yeah, like a dream state. I definitely have that happen when I'm doing for it,
but I also sometimes have that happened when I, and I read
even. So do you think that you and Lauren one will become friends?
Um, I
honestly probably,
no. No,
no.
Um, I, I mean we're just,
yeah, it's just, I just don't, I wouldn't, I would just want it,
but she's you
but not you. Don't you want to hang out with or don't you need to know her? No.
Okay. Thank you very much. Why don't you just sit down just for a second.
We're going to play a little nobody off I think, but there's more. Come on.
I think we can just repair all the damage that is just acute to your sensitive
psyche. Just listen and we'll be waiting.
[inaudible]
hi, this is [inaudible]. Hey, this is Lauren.
Lydia that is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science of technology in the modern world.
What's amazing about Sloan at www dot [inaudible] dot org Radiolab is produced
by so few NYC and distributed by NPR. Okay, bye. Bye.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create a website this new year,
make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website, squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
Our country continues to grapple with the deep cultural divisions exposed by the
2016 elections.
[inaudible] there is some palpable change in how people are looking at as well.
Maybe how we are looking at people.
W and YC is talking to a broad range of Americans about how we arrived at this
moment in our political culture. I'm Kai,
right subscribed to the United States of anxiety,
culture wars from wny sea studios, wherever you get your podcasts,
Chai reality, take 30,000 yeah, yeah.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and today we are desperately seeking symmetry.
Thus far we are failing desperately because maybe, maybe, you know, if we took,
if we rejiggered our whole approach because symmetry no is really about love.
No, it's it's way. Even though we're changing the subject now.
It's about the way things look when they're flipped around or turned or rotated.
And this is where it gets really interesting. Reflected, reflected, yes.
Reflected because there was a map affected. Yes.
There was a mathematician at Oxford University named Charles Latoya. AJ Datsun.
There's a mathy named for you. Well, he had a different name as it happens.
What? Lewis Carroll. Oh, like the Alice in wonderland. The Alice in wonderland.
Dude, he is a mathematician. He was, I had really didn't know that.
Did you know that he wrote another book called through the looking glass?
Truthfully, I didn't know they were different books. You know,
very little in this particular section,
but there's a part of the book where Alice is standing in her room talking to
her cat.
Now if you'll only attend kitty and not talk so much,
I'll tell you all about my ideas about looking glass house.
This is Natasha gastric reading in in this section of the book,
Alice is telling her cat like,
let's take a look at the difference between our world and that world right there
in the mirror. That's just the same as our drawing them.
Only the things go the other way.
The books are something like our books, only the words go the wrong way.
I know that because I've had at one of our books to the glass and then they hold
that one in the other room.
How would you like to live in a looking glass house? Katie?
I one day. If, if you look in that
paps looking glass, milk isn't good to drink.
Perhaps your milk isn't good to drink.
Why you? Why you dug in like that and what does that even mean? Well,
you just stick with me on this. I think I will make it [inaudible]
physically clear. Okay. This is a very, as it turns out, yes.
Difficult scientific question. Yes. They call it a [inaudible]. Okay. What?
This is Neil degrasse Tyson, n. E. I. L.
Degress small d e capital g. R. A. S. S. E. Tyson.
He's an astrophysicist with the American Museum of Natural History,
also the director of the Hayden Planetarium. Cool. And what is that?
What is [inaudible]? Well, it's when you make a molecule,
there's no rule or law that says it has to be symmetric. Neil says,
if you zoom into that bowl of milk,
what you're gonna find is just chains of atoms that are stuck together in a very
particular shape and that shape, it could curl in a particular way.
So for example, if you have a spring and you turn your finger in the direction,
the spring, spring, like a coil, a coil,
but like the spring out of your click pen, pull off that spring. All right,
we have a pen right here under your pen. Pull it out and got the spring out.
Here we go. And look at the way the spring turns. Nothing.
You got to spray and move your finger in the direction utter in moving.
My finger is turning clockwise
all the way up to the top. Okay?
That spring is that way in
it's life. Whether it's right side up or upside down, it doesn't matter.
Always clockwise. But if you had a mirror jad you happen to have something.
Do I have a mirror? No. [inaudible] take your phone.
Has that reflected the shiny thing. Okay. Put Your um,
spring in front of the shiny surface of the phone. Okay.
Trace the spring with your finger and tell me which direction is your finger
going? Collect wise? No, we already did this in the reflection. Oh,
in the phone to Kinda tell but no phone.
It's going the opposite way. Yes. Counter-Clockwise. Exactly.
And so now you have two opposite oppositely turned springs.
You cannot turn one into the other.
They're built differently yet they are curiously identical. Yeah.
So since molecules are just sequences of Adams,
imagine a molecule that has that shape.
If you put that molecule in front of the mirror, just the same as the spring,
you've got now two molecules built differently, but curiously identical,
blah, blah, blah.
Kind of like your right hand and your left hand,
your left hand and your right hand are related by a mirror image.
It's the same thing with these molecules. This is Marcelo Gleiser.
He's a physicist at Dartmouth college and according to Marcello,
this is how scientists talk about molecules. They call them, right?
We use these. Sometimes we call it a hand in there.
Sometimes you get a little more fancy and we call it Chi or Allity because Cairo
Kiros in Greek means hand and Marcelo says,
if you look at pebbles or granted or cement inanimate stuff,
when you look at the shape of things inside,
it's a mixture of the two 50% lefthanded, 50% right-handed.
However, if you look at all the proteins of living things,
they're always lefthanded and no right-handed at all.
Really wife has chosen one over the other life as we know it has chosen.
When scientists look inside of living things, they, that they always see it.
The molecules are pointing one way. Yeah. Right. So somehow,
and this is what's really amazing,
somehow life is choosing a very specific shape for the molecules to make up
stuff. That's correct. When you say life has chosen,
let's take that sentence apart.
Life meaning everything that is that we know of on earth, every living thing,
hence my phrase, life as we know it, everything. That's what that means.
The littlest things to the blue whale that would be as we know,
the littlest clean new thing to the street, the biggest tree,
the giant sequoia, that would be as we know, every protein in you,
dogs, trees, you name it. It's filled with left-handed building blocks. Yes.
It's called the [inaudible] of life. The Chi reality of life life.
My friend is left hinted.
[inaudible] that's pretty, that's a well it feels cool, but, and let me just,
uh, like so what
I mean, I don't want to put it bluntly, but I mean w well other than the
sheer surprise of having everything in life being shaped and when directing,
but I mean, what does it have to do with my life? Well,
this bringing one's life, this brings us backing.
This brings us back to the mirror mystery and Alice in the mirror and milk. No,
no, because you, because you just told me that,
that the milk is left-handed because milk is an Ocala living cow. Yeah.
Remember you said that life is lefty [inaudible] so there can't be any
right-handed milk. So the mirror milk doesn't exist.
Well that's because I forgot to tell you that scientists all the time
manufacture mirror molecules. They do. Yeah. Yeah.
They go into their laboratories and they synthetically make mirror molecules of
all kinds of things. Can they do milk? Mironov about milk in particular.
But I do know that when I talked to an Oxford professor, Marcus does a toy,
right? Yeah. He told me, if you take the atoms which built caraway seeds,
which is the space they use in Rye bread, take a mirror image of them.
Suddenly you get something which tastes of Spearman, Huh?
Is What's put on Wrigley spearmint gum. And in fact,
there are some very dramatic examples of this, not just where the taste changes,
but um, uh,
listeners might remember a story about the thalidomide drug.
In 1958, a West German pharmaceutical firm began marketing a new drug.
This is a new spot from the early 1960s.
He said it though so effective and apparently harmless.
It quickly became one of the most widely used and prescribed drugs in west
Europe, illegitimate
before long pregnant women started taking it as a way to come. Morning sickness.
And most of us, well, we know what happened next.
Every a woman President Kennedy in a press conference in this country, I think,
uh, must be aware that it's most important that they take this drug,
that they turn it in every citizen. Of course, I should be aware of the hazards.
All in all more than 12,000 children were born with arms and legs that were
shortened or deformed or completely missing.
The strange thing according to Marcus is that we now know they're the drunk.
When they first made the [inaudible] it was all one hand,
let's say it's was left handed. Yeah.
And it did actually cure me with morning sickness and was completely harmless.
But somewhere along the way, thalidomide flipped.
We don't know whether this was in the drug making process or after,
but we do know it's mirror image was incredibly poisonous.
So you know what this means jet in a show about symmetry.
What we've just discovered is that life itself is actually deeply asymmetric.
Yeah. Unlike love where we started the program back with, um,
Aristophanes when it comes to life, you don't want to meet the other half,
stay away, may run the other way away. Anyhow,
that's well enough about me or no, no, no, no, no.
I think we can take this another step further. There is no further, I mean,
because something about this chemistry reflections thing resonates for me with
the actual experience of standing in
front of a mirror. How will you know, you look at that guy and you're like, Eh,
oof. I mean,
we talked about this on stage actually in d c at the Shakespeare theater.
Remember when I asked you that personal question? Do you want to do that?
Oh yes, we do. Psychologically. Let me ask psychologically, do you,
do you enjoy looking in the mirror?
Is that a question you want to ask me in front of the,
I thought that's a private question. I, you surely,
you know though that you are, uh,
the difference between your true self and your mirror itself is not trivial.
My true. What did you mean by my true self? I don't know. Well,
I'm going to tell you the story now. Okay. About a guy named John Walter. Oh,
the, with the Luma staff from Baltimore, from the movies, you know,
that's John Waters. Walter.
He's a computer programmer in new Rochelle.
Paid him a visit recently cause back when he was in college he sorta kindness
switched places with the guy in the mirror. It was many years ago.
How old were you? I was 19, 19. So it was a long time ago.
We're talking late seventies here, but I was um, uh,
had already had some issues with the mirror. So let me set this up for you.
The thing to know about John is that as a kid he had a tough time.
Like so many of us, he would get bullied, beaten up on the playground.
It was no better when he got into his teens. And as a 19 year old,
his social life consisted of a series of stinging humiliations like the
following. I remember at the time there was a lot of um, kids hanging out.
You know, there was a crew of people like, you know, 20, 30,
40 kids would gather together at the aqueduct beautiful words that have the
aqueduct and go drink beers and smoke cigarettes. You know,
I've walked into the group, I care what's up. And it's like, yeah, whatever.
Roundly rejected and that according to John was normal.
That was normal. Very normal. Like people would say,
what's that guy doing here? Yeah,
maybe he was like wearing the wrong plaid pants or had like, you know,
mismatch socks. They might be something, whatever. Don't you emphasize?
I of course with this guy,
nobody wants to be 19 and be the yucky person in class. I would input however,
the story that will follow centers on a revelation that John had that uh,
began just as he was about to start his summer job for con Ed.
I was working for them as a painter and I had some pictures taken for con Ed.
These are id photos that you guys have an ID camera that had four lenses.
So when they took the negative, there was four of me. Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Like little squares, squares. And I remember looking over and, and, and going,
why do I look so weird?
Why do it look so weird? Why? Why did it look so weird?
Because here's the thing. I mean,
the John in the pictures was not the John that he knew himself to be,
that John was kinda timid and nerdy. Not Cool.
Why do I look so weird in pictures? I look fine. What do you mean you look fine?
Do you know? You look fine.
Well, I thought I looked fine in the mirror. You know,
and when I looked at my course in the mirror, things on the left,
go to the right things on the right. Go to the left. Wait a second.
That's when it hit him. What? What hit him?
It's the hair apart. It's the what?
It's the hair part. It's the what? It's the hair part.
I could do this all night. It's the hair part. What does that mean? It's the,
hey, I hear it. I hear it. I'd be like, what's that? You eat the hair part.
Well, in the picture, I saw a guy with a right hair part in the mirror.
I seen the guy with the left hair part essentially John, wait, which part?
Which side am I here? Part it on. Is Your left your left? My left. Okay.
John Thought he was a lefty too.
He would stand in front of the mirror and the mirror would tell him he was
parting it to the left,
but in fact he was partying it to the right in real life.
Now the lefty guy in the mirror, he liked that guy. I was fine with that guy.
He was cool. He was, there was nothing wrong with him,
but he realized he was the only person seeing that guy. So we thought,
Oh, let me put my hair on the other side.
Let me essentially swap real me for mirror me.
It was one of these things where, yeah, that looks really weird in the mirror,
but at Betcha it looks good in real life. Let me go find out.
What did you do well that night
[inaudible]
it goes back to the aqueduct. Same posse is there as before
that same group. Interesting enough,
had beat the crap out of me like three years earlier when I was in like ninth
grade,
but there he was now with his hair parted on the left. He says,
this time things were different. Somebody offered him a beer.
Well was like, wow.
But the thing that I knew made it better was when I left,
I got goodbyes.
[inaudible]
come on. My God, I Look God for the first time. I'm, no,
this is ridiculous that you would tell me a story about a man who is having
social failures. University shifts. His Arrow is remade. This is like,
it's his experience. It's very easy to dismiss,
but when you already, are you ready? I'm going to win you over.
You're not ready for this. I don't think you're ready. Are you ready?
If you are asking me to be [inaudible],
I'm going to show you a picture right now. All right. Okay. Have a look at,
okay. At who is that? It's Abraham Lincoln, our 16th president.
[inaudible] private. Take him in. Taking deep into your consciousness.
By the way. This next part,
you can see the pictures@radiolab.org it's worth checking out. All right.
His eyes, his nose, his mouth. Pay attention particularly to the hair part.
Okay, now look what happens when you flip Abraham.
Oh, that.
No, no, no, no, no, no. Guys. Is this the same picture? Picture?
Go back to the other picture. Go. Alright, here's a, now we'll do the other one.
Oh, you see so weird. No. Here's the thing.
This is what Abraham Lincoln would have when he looked in the mirror.
He would have seen this guy, not the other guy. The one we all see. Huh?
So there's something going on you. Would you not at least acknowledge me?
They find this. Okay, with your permission,
Mr Sinek,
I will now rejoin John Who's about to get married and have three babies cause
his hair. He says after, after he switched his part,
it just kept getting better and better and better all summer long.
He was suddenly invited to all of these parties,
but the very same people used to beat him up and for the first time he says
clearly one of them. Now, whether you're not you buy that,
this is in fact because of his hair that's on you. Okay,
but let's fast forward just a little bit. The next summer,
this would have been 1979 and 1979 John sitting in front of the TV and on comes.
Good evening. This is a special night for me. The precedent Jimmy Carter
making a speech about how our nation is in a deep
fuck.
Why have we not been able to get together as a nation to resolve our serious
energy problems? Then malaise speech.
You know that that infamous countries in malaise clear that the true problems of
our nation, a much deeper,
deeper than gasoline lines or energy shortages,
deeper even than inflation
session. Now, as you know,
I'm sure you remember a lot of people would criticize Jimmy Carter for making
the speech because he's up there admitting flaws and they were like,
come on Mr President. Don't be weak man up John.
Meanwhile is sitting in front of the TV and he's thinking, dude,
you gotta change your hair part.
[inaudible]
and so I wrote him, cause I wrote to him, I wrote to him, wait, wait.
So you said, wait,
what is why I think I just said I think you should change your hair. Pardon?
On the on the left I did myself and found it to be much more powerful, much,
much more successful. And um, that six, I so wish I did. I don't have it.
Um, and then about six weeks later, boom, he twitched. He switched. No, he,
John wrote him a letter and President Carter switched.
Now it might not have been John's letter that didn't have no evidence.
Thinking about how much, what's involved in a president switching his hair.
There are focus groups. There are prayer meetings.
There's so much thought that goes into the, did anyone actually record this?
They did. I will. I will now read you a journalistic account from no, no.
P A periodical. There you go. Washington book right there.
You see Bam right there. Oh Man. Newsweek,
May 7th, 1979 at first, photographers thought they had their negatives reversed,
but no, Jimmy Carter has changed the partner,
his hair from the right side to the left,
the Washington press score demanded an explanation,
buck
silver that, you know, as opposed to John who changes it here.
And then all the girls give them beers. This guy,
he was running against a luxuriantly haired man,
the Reagan and it didn't matter. So he just, you know, we got crushed. Right.
You know what? Forget smart. Forget the executive branch. Yeah,
stay with me now. Um,
I was with John and he was showing me pictures of congressmen and of celebrities
and uh, I noticed something peaking out at the bottom of the pile.
I see peaking out on beneath the stack of photos as a superman. Yeah.
Show me a picture of Superman looking mighty in his superman suit.
Notice how he parts his hair. It's a little bit on there. On that side. Yeah.
Now this is Clark Kent.
And as we know from the movies, Clark Kent is fumbling sort of a dork.
I was at first, really nervous about tonight.
So somebody who made that movie maybe explicitly intuitively understood
something about the difference that maybe you know the right parts said.
One thing about Clark Kent, the left part said something about superman.
In fact,
there is a scene in the movie where Clark Kent's running down an alley.
He's about to turn into superman.
He pulls his shirt open to reveal the es and literally mid-stride his hair goes
and turns from the hood to the left.
So you're saying that sophisticated popular cultural motion picture
manufacturers,
at least two presidents have been persuaded to this position at this very moment
on a Saturday night. That is what I'm saying. All right,
well for argument's sake that, what would you say, I hate to get into this,
any paper explains the difference between putting the power of your hair on the
left hand or the right hand. Well, if you ask John,
what he'll say is that the left hair part emphasizes strength and logic because
it draws your attention to the logical,
more masculine side of your face, your brain.
Cause it's a left brain kind of thing. But I don't really know.
So I decided I would actually take this seriously and figure out how to feel
about it. So I call up this guy. His name is Mike Nichols. Oh,
from graduate. There's the mic.
A very good a psychology professor in Australia is an expert in symmetry that
Mike Nichols, I ran him through John's theory.
Have you ever seen the superman movies? Some of the earlier ones. I think,
you know how Clark Kent's hair as part of the right ran through the whole thing,
you know, Clark's on the rain, maybe he's weeks you've met lab,
maybe you stronger, more assertive. Is there anything to that?
Anything at all? Um, yeah, I mean possibly, you know,
um, uh, but,
but, but he didn't say this, which is interesting in focusing on the left,
John Maybe picking up on a particular bias that we human beings have to our left
side. For instance, here's an experiment that uh,
he and his colleagues did like a snapshot of someone's face, um,
at baseline when they're showing no emotion blank face and then get them to try
to look as happy or sad as I could take happy guy.
And overlay him onto no expression guy and almost like a contour map.
You could actually look at the amount of change,
the amount of muscle movement and that it occurred,
which you will see if you measure the muscle movement in millimeters on each
side of the face.
You'll see that the smile curves a few extra millimeters on the left side of the
face. He says this is nearly always the case. Always on the left side.
What it's really telling you is that when somebody smiles or when they frown or
whatever,
they're doing it slightly more strongly on the left side of their face.
Now if this is the case that our left side is sort of saying more emotionally
than our right side, then if you think about the mirror,
it's kind of a discombobulating thing. You know, cause it's taken your left,
which is sort of broadcasting emotion, flipping it to your right.
You're seeing yourself, your own mixed up.
You don't know which part of you is where you, so you're saying like,
because I tend to address you with my attention on your left side,
unbeknownst to me.
And your left side is actually flipped over to your rights at I don't, I,
it's a where are we? So it's exactly, but John has uh,
has developed a solution to this uh, problem.
Take this one apart now.
Makes and sells his own very special mirrors right out of his home.
And is this where you make everything to get goes into the mirror is made here.
Um, you see here, this is the machine that cuts the mirror.
He buys these giant sheets of reflective glass and he slices them into little
pieces,
clunk. And then I snap it.
Now for each mirror, uh, this is the key.
He uses two pieces of mirror glass instead of one.
What he'll do is he'll take these two pieces and he'll place them together at a,
at right angles, two mirrors at right angles. Like exactly at right angles.
It has to be a 90.0 degrees. And let's just push this up a little bit.
It's still not enough n****s. When he finally gets it right,
which can take hours. What he'll have is this v shaped Miri. He'll stand it up,
put it in a box, and then Voila.
What you have is a mirror that shows you a mirror image of a mirror image of you
takes the normally flipped guy that you'd see in the mirror,
re flips him so that what you are seeing is essentially, well,
for the first time in a mirror you see yourself as other people see you. Okay,
so there you go. So what is this that you have in your head? This is,
this is a true mirror. This is that to the 12 inch model. And so when you like,
this is actually what I look like at touch. You're right. I see.
It's actually on the right side. Oh my God. Isn't that crazy? That's crazy.
It is surprisingly weird to see yourself this way.
I feel like my nose is going the wrong way. Yeah.
I never knew my nose went that way and this little flare in my eyebrows is on
the wrong side or the right side as it were.
John claims that many a fair number. I probably would put you in this bunch.
My cohost, when they stand in front of this mirror,
they a freak out many of them because they, it's
just their perception is this shaken up a little bit. In fact,
he sometimes takes his mirrors to these festivals and who will sort of set them
up and have people look at themselves and then fill out comment cards
afterwards. You know what I mean? If you look at some of the comments, you know,
it's like they're monster.
I am
monster anymore here. What did he say? I am a,
may
monster in your mirror.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
to break, we go. If you want any more information on anything you heard,
go to our website,
radiolab.org or if you want to see those incredible pictures of Abe Lincoln,
that's where they are. Yes. Rate and subscribe to our podcast there as well.
[inaudible].
Hi, this is Eleanor Womack from Brooklyn, New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
okay. Hey, I'm jet. I boom, rod.
I remembered Krulwich this is radio lab and today you're still desperately
looking, seeking symmetry as you say. Oh, not well yet. We have looked at love,
failed, looked at brain veiled, look at mirrors, chemistry of life.
So we thought, well for the last stop on this trip,
if we were to go anywhere to find or look for deep unity,
a deep oneness and symmetry. Maybe the beginning. Yeah, of everything. Zero.
So we found ourselves a physicist. Again, it's Neil degrasse Tyson.
I began with a very, very basic question.
If you look at me and I look at you and you seem to be made of stuff and I seem
to be made of stuff and here we are and here our tables and chairs.
Is it surprised you in some deep way that we are all here made of stuff?
Yes. It's, it's not so much surprise. Understates it, it's shocking.
Really. It's shocking, Huh? What is,
what is shocking that there's any matter in the universe at all?
Meaning that this conversation shouldn't be happening no deeper the mouth.
It's deeper than just whether or not we'd be having this conversation.
It's whether or not any of this would exist. Earth, the galaxy and the like.
Whew.
Okay. So, um, if you go back 13.7 billion years ago,
that's my shallow Glaser again, the physicist and he says,
if you rolled back the history, the universe, no more stars,
no molecules, no atoms can play the movie backwards. Now,
all the weeks to the beginning, just after you know,
the Big Bang, you have what we call a primeval
soup. This soup was actually was made of light,
universe of light, very high energy and out of this energy, this heat,
this interactions, you suddenly get [inaudible].
What this tells us is that these are belches Jad,
belches noches of matter. The light is doing this. Yes.
This is the what equals mc squared is all about,
because energy is just a form of matter. And vice versa.
I feel like I should know what you're talking about, but I don't. Okay, let's,
let's start. Let's start a little simpler. There's light all around us.
We're in a studio. It's visible light. So this light
has no mass, has energy. Even o m [inaudible] crank up the energy of the light,
go to ultra violet x-rays,
and there's a point in x-rays where you have a high enough x-ray photon,
it will spontaneously
[inaudible]
turn into a particle. Electrons. In fact. Oh,
so you're saying if you crank up the e the energy at the light high enough,
it'll suddenly just turn into mass. That's correct. So just picture the soup.
Well,
really intensely hot and it's belching out to do.
I left trons Zumi around. Oh, Tom Parks.
Each man neutrinos continuously churning,
churning, churning. Over time,
all that matter clumps together in more and more complex forms until you finally
get
us.
Sounds really simple, doesn't it? Chat? Yes, but there's a, but coming.
I can smell it, but, and here's the big butts.
Knew it back in 1928 1929 there was this physicist,
young guy, Paul Dirac,
he's doing some math and he's thinking about this whole business of turning
light into matter. Okay? Now he's puzzled by something. What?
There is a law in physics called the law of conservation of charge,
which simply means this. It rolls off your tongue quite nicely, doesn't it?
It does. So here's what it means. Whenever you create something,
if it in the beginning you have zero electric charge at the end you have to have
zero electric charge to that is you cannot create electric charge.
You have to keep the balance.
If you make something in the universe that has a positive charge or a net,
like make an electron, okay, just make one right now. Yeah,
gone. That Electron has eight you remember,
remember this from eighth grade eight
negative one baby, make two electrons.
Now make three electrons negative three.
Now if the university is to stay in balance,
you need to have something that has a positive charge.
You got three minuses on one side.
You have nothing on the other side in a second. If this is true,
how would you even make an electron?
The sheer fact of creating an electron puts it out of balance. Well, here's,
here's the metal story. Here's Ron. Well, no, Paul that. Well, how about this?
What if every time you created an electron,
you created an entire electron?
What every particle could have an equal but opposite in tight particle that is a
particle that looks very much the same,
but essentially it's electric charge is reversed. It would look the same,
like really look, yes,
you'd have to measure their properties to know that they were different.
Is it a mirror image or am I think of it as a mirror image?
There's a thing called quantum spin and it would just be spinning the opposite
way, but charges the most obvious difference. For example,
the anti-matter cousin of the electron because the electron is a negative
charge. This little guy should have a positive charge. Exactly,
but in every other way it would be the same. Right, and no one ever seen one.
He just thought that there probably would be one. Yes.
And why did he think this? Math. Math.
It was a solution to these equations.
And that's the beauty of theoretical physics. I solve your equations.
You can sometimes find out about the world. And then yes, a few years later,
quite a bit, they found the positron,
the anti-matter version of the electron. Oh yeah, no, it's deep in steam.
How did they do that? Like see it? Well, particles, um, you know,
they're very tiny, right? You can't really see them. So all you do is, uh, you,
you create little systems in the laboratory.
You get like a vapor and you put the vapor in a tank, he says,
and when the electron or the Anti Electron shoots through the vapor,
the particle destabilizes the vapor and makes little bubbles. Okay.
You can see these little bubbles appearing out of nothing. Ah, seriously.
An amazing thing. So you can't see the particle itself,
but you can see its shadow. It's road trip. It's road trip. Yeah.
So then he says, okay,
imagine you get this little piece of light and heat it up really hot so that it
spawns, or as we've learned, not one particle but two matter anti-matter pair,
put them in the uh, vapor tank and you put a magnet in there.
You can tell if it's going to the left or to the right if it's a positive or
negative charge. It is cool.
You see two particle tracks that each curl opposite directions and if they have
the same rate of curl, that means they have the same mass.
So if we go back to our picture of the early universe that the soup which,
and you named all of those particles,
does that mean that for every particle that you named there is its opposite
floating around there as well. Exactly. You have electrons, anti electronics.
We try to answer a neutron and
Proton Antiproton this is all very beautiful and you'd say, great,
I have a very democratic universe, you know,
has many particles and antiparticles and everybody's happy.
All your problem is the following. When an alarm electron and a positron meet,
they will find each other and oh,
and they will annihilate you.
Even they'll find something because they'll find their original other hand. No,
no. They wouldn't need to know. Just find another kind like that's correct.
That's correct. So Chad, now imagine that we're in the very early universe.
I am a teeny bit of matter. And you opposite, I'm an anti cro,
which an anti code.
And so the procrit which is sitting here and I see you across the,
he's now I'm positive. Charge your name,
we charge the charges track year round.
You see it doesn't work out too well for us. But you know, he, wait, wait,
this is actually a rather profound puzzle because if Paul Dirac was right and
half the universe is matter, the other half of the universe is Andy mattered.
And we all bumped into each other as we just did.
Well eventually I guess we would just not, we would just become,
I don't what, Oh, I don't know. We would not be here.
Dan just blink out and there'd be nothing. Exactly.
Really nothing.
So it's a field of mostly not mostly just
radiation, radiation, radiation, radiation, radiation,
radiation, radiation, radiation.
[inaudible].
Well,
there's something wrong with this theory because we are talking to each other.
Yeah. So something, something's wrong with this notion. Yes.
And what's wrong is that imperfection in the laws of physics that we know of now
and that, uh, is responsible for this bias. What, which means what day was that?
There was a little more of of matter, but we call matter than,
than anti matter or, yes.
There was to be precise to every billion particles of anti-matter.
We had 1,000,000,001 ah, particles of matter. Oh my God.
Really? Yes. Oh, that's tiny.
Excess of one in a billion is enough to create everything that exists now.
Lonely little guy.
We would call that an asymmetry.
[inaudible]
so everything we see in the universe, all the stars,
all the suns and the moons and the graft and the mountains and us,
although we're the left, we're the extra stuff. Yes,
we are the result of this asymmetry.
Has Anybody dealt with the real question that's provoked here? It's like,
why was there more of one stuff kind of stuff. Then the other kind of stuff.
So there you go. That is one beautiful question,
but we don't have any on any
final answer yet. You don't know because you see,
you don't all know. We do not know. That's right. Which is okay.
Not knowing is a wonderful thing in science, otherwise it could just retire.
Can I tell you my favorite lawyer joke told to me by a lawyer? Yeah.
I have to spread this cause it's the best one.
98% of lawyers give the other 2% of bad names.
Well that's the go music and go music meaning go away.
Or here's a different place to go to our website,
radiolab.org where you can read more about anything you heard in this era.
You can see those amazing Lincoln picks and other things we've got there on
symmetry. And of course you can subscribe to our podcast,
which we usually get to hear the show. You know, whenever you like,
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich.